Thank you all so much for joining this afternoon.
I'm going to speak loudly because I know the room
is a little loud, but really appreciate you joining our
session and hopefully you're going to walk away here and
expert in post training open source models and deploying them
in agents to scale your AI across your company.
As you all know, agents are extremely impactful.
They're changing the way we all work.
And I've had the pleasure of working with many of
you, many customers, both outside of Microsoft enterprises and startups
alike, as well as Teams inside Microsoft shipping some of
the agents that you might have used in your daily
work.
And one of the things that we are consistently learning
is that deploying a model into production is just the
beginning.
We all, just like every software application we deployed, need
to focus on continuously learning and improving them to make
sure that they perform at scale on all the different
edge cases that we might not have thought about.
And So what we're going to do today is show
you exactly how to do that, to learn and improve,
to drive down your costs and improve your quality, to
get faster, better, cheaper agents using Foundry.
I'm really excited to walk you through this because one
of the other things that we've been learning is that
agents are extremely token hungry.
As we offload all of our cognitive processing, our thinking,
our work to the cloud to agents, we're seeing a
substantial increase in the token consumption as compared to regular
chat bots.
And this makes sense because agents are doing multiple iterative
tool calls.
They're rationing, rationalizing over the data that they fetch from
our enterprise systems, our databases, and validating our policies.
And they need to think about what to do with
this information.
And in doing so, the costs increase.
So as you scale your agents, you're scaling up your
bill as well.
So one of the things that we're going to show
you is that how to potentially reduce that cost by
learning from your production agents, using the power of reinforcement
learning to make sure that your cost remain flat while
your quality is also flat or in even increases over
time.
Now to do that, one of the powerful techniques that
you can employ is post training or fine tuning.
People use these terms interchangeably, and fine tuning is extremely
important because it teaches your models to think and act
the way that you want them to.
Not only can you teach them your business domain, you
can teach them how to use your tools to interact
with your systems that are required to take action on
your behalf.
And in doing so, you can eliminate potentially erroneous interactions,
which are costly.
Now, we've all been leveraging the power of the latest
frontier models, and they're extremely intelligent.
They can learn how to use your tools and usually
perform pretty darn well.
But while they're rationalizing all of the different potential tools
that you might have given to your agents, their thinking
and their course correcting is costing you money.
And so by fine tuning your models, you can ensure
that they are choosing the best tools for the job
in the right order to achieve the best outcome at
the lowest price.
And one of the ways that you can do that
by using Foundry is to facilitate not only selecting the
best models, but then also ensuring that you have the
right tools in your agent and you bring in the
right evals into the whole process.
And this is critically important.
And we're going to explain how all of these come
together by using Foundry to facilitate getting faster, better and
cheaper find, using fine tuning and deploying the models and
agents to production that continuously learn.
So the first step in this whole process is figuring
out which models are appropriate for your workload.
And that's getting increasingly complicated because there are new models
coming out all the time.
The good thing is Foundry has all of the models
you could possibly want to choose from and maybe even
more, and we're adding to them continuously.
The key to making sure that you've got the right
model for your agent is the scientific method, which is
guess and check.
Now we're going to show you how to do that
checking process, which is the most critical step.
And that's in scientific terms here is called evaluation.
So by evaluating the the models, you can ensure that
you have the best one for the job.
Now let me show you precisely how we can go
through and select different models and then we'll show you
how to evaluate them and then improve them over time.
So here I have Microsoft Foundry and I'm in the
context of an agent for a customer service retail scenario.
And a customer wants to be able to return a
particular product that they purchased recently.
And in doing so, we need to not only sure
ensure that we interact with the agent or the customer
in a friendly way.
We need to make sure that all of our policies
are honored, maybe do order look UPS, make sure that
they actually got their product, that that sort of thing.
And so we can do that with a frontier model
like the GPT 5 Series.
And it's extremely good at figuring all these things out.
We can also do that same thing with a smaller
model like the Quen 314B model, which is an open
source model.
And it's also capable of thinking and figuring things out.
It may not necessarily be as powerful as the GPT
5 model, but we can see that it can still
kind of reason over what it should do.
Now the question is, how do we make sure that
these models consistently do what they're supposed to do?
If we look at how these actually work, we can
dig in and Microsoft Foundry collects not only all of
the telemetry that is required to continuously monitor how well
things perform in production, but we can drill in and
we can see the details of any given particular trace.
So we can see that for the particular request to
the agent, we can see it kind of went back
and forth multiple times.
It executed some of the tools that I gave it,
which are needed to understand the context of the customer,
the order and what's appropriate.
And then it reasoned over that data.
It did a loop a couple of times.
And we can see for each one of these chat
scenarios, each one of these tool calls, the costs are
increasing.
And so the smaller of a model that we can
run with to achieve the scenario, achieve the quality bar
that you're looking for, the higher the probability we can
do so in a cost efficient manner.
Now, what I'm going to show you as well is
how to evaluate the quality, because this is the key
thing.
You should only choose the models that are going to
hit your quality bar.
And you would not deploy any sort of application to
production without ensuring that's true.
Now in Foundry, we have this collection of evaluators that
are built in as well as custom evaluations.
And So what are evals exactly?
Let me explain.
So evaluators are the product spec.
As a product manager, this is extremely important to me
and it's incredibly important to everyone to make sure that
you define your success criteria before you deploy anything to
production.
Doesn't mean just hitting your quality bar, but making sure
that your policies are honored, making sure that the right
tools are called, and more.
This is a multi dimensional optimization technique.
You can use the built in evaluators or create custom
evaluators in Foundry to facilitate complex analysis of how all
of these things are interacting.
But first, in order to do that, you have to
define what does good mean to you and that is
what an eval is.
So I want you to think about this a little
bit differently than teams have in the past.
In the past, people have thought about this as when
I deploy the production that I'm going to monitor whether
things are going well.
I want you to shift that on its head.
Define what going well looks like to you and that
enables you to continuously hill climb to get to a
high quality output.
And we're going to show you today why that is
extremely important.
Benchmarks for any model, whether they're provided by a frontier
lab, an open source initiative, doesn't matter.
Benchmarks are only information that someone else has decided they
should publish.
It is a good starting point to learn from, but
you have to test the models on your own scenarios
on your own data to make sure that then you
can hit your success criteria when shipping to production.
And that is what evaluators enable.
We have a bunch of them in Foundry that are
built in as a good place to start.
But your custom evaluators are what is going to help
you ensure that you can continuously hill climb in a
way that matters to you.
And so the way that we do that in Foundry,
you can see we've got several of these custom eval
jobs that have run and I'll open one up and
we can see that my definition of quality, these different
evaluators, I've interactively tested these against multiple different agents that
I've deployed in production.
And I've created a unified metric retail quality that we
want to optimize for.
And we can see that my first set of agents
that I've deployed and tested, the first versions weren't really
that great.
The model quality was good like that on its own
can be used for many things.
But in the context of this agent and in the
context of the way I've defined quality with my evals,
I can actually tell that it's not doing that great.
And so the question is how to improve it.
And that is the whole point of the talk today
is we're going to go through how exactly to optimize
these agents based on your custom evaluators using the power
of post training on these open source models.
So what we're going to show you is to how
to we started with, in this particular case, a particular
Frontier model that was pretty good out-of-the-box, didn't have to
do any work at 76% quality, not bad, not great.
We want to get to 90% or better in order
to ship to production.
And the question is how.
We started with choosing a very small, very cost efficient,
10X lower costs than the Frontier model, but the quality
was a little bit worse.
That's going in the wrong direction.
Then we'll show you how to use the power of
both supervised fine tuning and reinforcement learning based fine tuning
on that open source model to eventually get to the
quality bar that we're looking for.
And to do that, I'm going to ask Vijay ask
you to come up to the stage and he'll walk
you through how to use Foundry to achieve this scenario.
OK.
Thank you everybody for coming.
So we'll learn couple important keywords today.
Post training, this is a word that's popularized by labs
like Open AI and Tropic, etcetera, and you don't get
to hear more often.
So usually you talk about fine tuning and reinforcement, fine
fine tuning or RLHF.
Post training is an umbrella term that encompass all of
those things.
But let's talk about post training in the context of
how a model is trained.
So anytime a model is trained, take any model that
you have like open AI model, open source, open source
models, Mai model, anthropic models.
They go through three distinct stages of how the model
is getting ready.
1 is called pre training, mid training and post training.
They are three different cycles independently varying from each other.
It is not a contiguous thing.
You can start from anywhere and continue with anywhere and
what you do in each of the stages matters and
how expensive they are matters, right.
So there are three things that you vary when you
are training a model data and you have your compute
and you have your model architecture or parameters.
So if you look at what is happening in the
pre training is orders magnitude more data is orders magnitude
more compute and the parameter is pretty like the models
parameter can be pretty huge and all of the weights
are being changed.
That's where the model is learning about the world and
it knows how to be intelligent, so to speak.
The mid training is very infused specialized knowledge.
The specialized knowledge could be anything from language to coding
or anything of that matter.
That's what you do.
Post training is where the model gets good at doing
the work that you need it to do in terms
of agent workflow, for example.
So when you're trying to get your agents to work,
the agents need to know how to kind of, let's
say, get everything right.
So, and most of the models are inherently good and
they're trained in the post training phase.
And today we're going to talk about post training as
a specialized topic.
So in post training, what's happening?
So just like how the models are being trained in
the Super, the labs, you can do post training by
yourself.
What does it mean to be post training?
So you see on the left side you have various
different ways where you distill your data.
Your data can be distilled from.
That's the agent that we have in production.
The traces, which is what we are going to talk
about Oregon, they could be human preferences or we call
sometimes, sometimes RLHF.
We have synthetic data that you could be picking data
from.
So you could get the data from any different ways.
And then on the right side, you see what do
you want to get the model to do.
You want the model to be, let us say safe,
safer than what it is as a base model or
do you want it to be good at particular task
bit coding or your agentic workflow?
Even though the base models keep getting better and better,
they do not know the rules that you are engaging
the model for.
Let us say if you want to have a support
ticket that you want somebody to handle or you have
any kind of workflow in a manufacturing unit or a
healthcare unit or anything for that matter, you the model
trainers or the base model does not know your specific
sequence.
So the way to get that right is kind of
do the same techniques that the labs do in your
setup.
But when you're doing that, you have you can have
two objectives.
1 is you want to get the model to be
like accurate and then task complete better for you guys
and also cheaper.
So when you take a large model, they are pretty
good at doing what they are doing, but because they
are trying to kind of discover the right thing, they
can be pretty expensive too.
And the model size, parameter size is very huge.
They need like lot more compute to kind of serve.
So they can be very expensive.
So as you kind of get into CLI or any
of these things, when you start coding and when you
start doing tasks, you realize that your token cost can
go up pretty fast.
And you heard a lot of examples in different these
days where somebody unwittingly spend like $1,000,000 or some cases
$5,000,000 without knowing that they are spending that much because
the token cost is that high.
And you want to basically reduce and post training is
the way to do that.
So what we are going to talk about here.
So post training has multiple recipes and the recipes.
So let us go back to the previous slide.
So, so the post training here, you can combine the
data in any of these data and try to optimize
for any of the skills on the left side, on
the right side.
And what you're doing there is you're basically doing one
at a time.
And when you're doing that, you're picking a recipe.
So today we're going to talk about one recipe that
includes fine distillation from the traces, fine tuning and RFT.
So fine tuning, this is something that most of the
people are familiar with.
So what's happening in fine tuning is you basically bring
in an expert and say, hey, here is a pattern
that I wanted to mimic.
So basically when you bring in customer response agent, you
want to say, hey, you want to have the tone
to be this way.
You want to have the format to be this way.
You kind of basically helping the agent know how to
kind of mimic.
The mimic can be the expert here, can be a
real expert, a human or the data, which basically is
formulated by an expert, right?
That's an example that we are choosing here in the
Box 1, which is demonstration.
And what you see happening in the Box 3, then
the tokens, you see the pink grading that's happening there.
It's basically grading the loss.
It's trying to figure out how close to the actual
expert answer the model answer is and it's grading it.
It is a loss function which says, hey, if it
is basically exactly the same or it is like partially
same and it rewards both of them, right?
And then you basically have the model weights get shifted
based on what is the right behavior that is SFT.
So SFT is basically telling you like mimic or the
kind of what to do, right?
So in terms of RFT, this is a order magnitude
more complex process and but it has the biggest bang
for the buck because these tasks are for verifiable tasks.
All the coding that you see the when the agents
are doing good at coding or math, for example, anything
that is like something that you can actually go and
verify and prove RFT is a way to teacher.
So let's say in the bottom here you're showing, let's
say to get a refund going, the model needs to
go get lot of sequences right, lot of policies, right?
And then make sure that each one of them is
hitting in the right order.
And the way to do that is by basically having
in the reinforcement fine tuning, each of the steps be
rewarded so that the model learns not just to mimic
but to also navigate paths that helps it get to
the right answer intuitively.
So that is what reinforcement fine tuning is.
So we are going to combine both reinforcement, fine tuning
and fine tuning with the distillation to get us to
where we need to so.
It's got locked up.
Yeah, I got it.
Yeah.
OK, so I have kicked off some jobs here.
So before that, let's go back to agents.
So Chris talked about the agents.
So let's say we have multiple agents.
So we see our agent, GPT 52.
So this is a powerful model and the agent is
using this model.
Now you're more likely that GPT 52 is probably giving
the best performance.
And now we 55 if you were to use and
you want to learn from how the best models do.
So you take you go and then figure out the
production traces.
And then production traces basically allows you to kind of
create a data set from that.
Let's say if you want to do reinforcement fine tuning
or fine tuning, you basically say, hey, I want to
distill expensive large model and then I want to potentially
kick off fine tuning itself.
I can start a fine tuning job right here.
So I've done something similar where I've created these data
sets previously.
So you could create.
So that's a continuous loop that we're talking about closing
the loop, you put the agent in production, see what
the agent does, take the traces and then kind of
start fine tuning those things.
So now if you so how do you basically start
your job?
So I will show you 2 two things today.
1 is a custom jobs.
The other one is a API that we are shipping
low level API.
Before that, if you want to do a custom jobs,
what we, you want to get yourself a box in
the cloud, what we call workbench or compute instance, where
you come in the machine is set up for you.
The workbench is set up for you so that you
don't have to worry about PIP installing all the dependencies
and everything else connected.
So you go in and say connect and then it
opens up a VS Code for you.
And then you basically start it on your core right
away.
And I already have something set up here that.
So this is a recipe that we talked about.
So here we are trying to teach the model how
to do your task better.
So we are starting with the base model and the
traces from there we are getting the agent traces and
then you are doing SFT and then you are doing
RFT and then you got to monitor and evaluate.
So in the traces.
So you take all the production traces, you filter down,
distill down, exactly what you want.
You pick the right traces and then figure out your
data set.
That's what the data set creation process that I just
showed is doing default.
But you can do it by yourself.
And then RFT is basically each of the examples, the
prompt that you have, you're rolling out, you're picking like
multiple samples based on different what the model response, pick
one of them and then follow the trajectory and then
reward the trajectory.
And you can kind of do that.
So, and then the ingredients that you have in your
setting up as you, for example, the business APIs that
you want to call, the graders that you want to
choose, the GPU clusters that you want to set up,
how many nodes that defines how fast the job runs,
how quickly the job runs.
You can do all of those things.
And then you kind of install the SDK, configure the
job, and then you kick off the job.
So let's do that.
I've done that already, but let's, I can run them
in any order.
So we have the setup as complete.
Then I can kick off a SFT job.
In the SFT job that I'm doing, you see that
you have the data that comes from the data set
that we just trained and the code you can bring
the code to.
So if you're an expert code or a data scientist,
you can bring the code.
You set up your computer clusters, you pick the model
of your choice, and you set up the SFT job.
And the SFT job generally creates a model that you
feed to the reinforcement fine tuning.
But for the sake of demo, we're not going to
wait for that to happen.
So once you kick off, it will actually show you
the job link that you can kind of go navigate
to in the RFT.
It is something different in reinforcement fine tuning, unlike SFT
like we talked about, it is more sophisticated.
So you can basically configure how the reward verification happens
and how basically how to arrive at the best answer.
So there is a concept of sampling training and roll
out.
So what that basically means is you take a prompt
that the customer agent prompt one of the prompts that
you have.
And then you create multiple samples, pick a sample and
then have multiple trajectories in which the model responds like
different orders, different sequence of calls, different ways it responds.
And then each one of them you pick and then
you grade them like we saw in the slide deck.
So you can set up all of those things in
here.
You can figure out how how many GPUs you want,
how many, like what kind of a topology that you
want for the clusters and then you submit your job
and then basically it'll give the link for you to
kind of go and navigate.
So I have done that previously.
So let's go back to our jobs and let's pick
RFT job in here.
And we have a authenticated ray endpoint where it's a
ray cluster which is running your all the GPUs and
CPU nodes.
And then you have a ray as a distributed engine
that's basically taking your Python code and distribute across the
different nodes.
And you can basically run your ray dashboard.
You can see that all the nodes are active and
the resource that is being used, both CPU resource and
GPU resources.
Let's say if you go look at your jobs in
here.
You can look at the jobs and see what's going
on in the job.
You see for each of the notes, each of the
actors, everything that's being run.
So you can kind of go further deep.
And then we basically see what each of the actors
are doing, what methods are calling, what functions calling.
So you can have complete visibility into what your job
is doing.
It's not just a fight and forget API.
So for advanced users, data scientists and developers, you can
actually be extremely meticulous about knowing what's happening at each
node in each cluster.
So you can actually go find that out.
And similarly for the cluster, if you want to see,
hey, how many nodes there are, they're all like, this
is at a cluster job level monitoring.
You can do that.
Now, if you go back like what we talked about,
the more interesting stuff is the rollouts that we talked
about, like what's happening with the rollouts?
Like why is the model behaving the way it's behaving
or grading the way it's grading?
So let's say see these are the rollouts in progress.
So we pick, let's say the rewards is kind of
increasing and some someones, someones are rated, rated well or
graded well, rather someones are not.
If you want to see why something is not graded
well, if you look at let's say the prompt 8,
so we've chosen 8 here.
So in here you will see for this particular sample
that's picked, what are the tools that it called and
in what order.
You see clearly it kind of missed calling each of
the functions in here.
So if it missed, obviously going to get lower rewards
and it's created lower.
That's why the grade was lower.
If you want to basically do a side by side
comparison with what a good run will look like.
So you basically have something here graded higher, and this
is not a good example.
So you can actually see a tool comparison with what
something went well, like let's pick a different one which
probably highlights it better.
Roll out 16.
So here you see one of them is the reason
for cancellation.
Expected outcome is to basically look for the reason for
cancellation.
Here you will see the tool calls a particular one
got it right, the other one didn't.
So you can actually see for each rollout why a
particular rollout is getting rewarded higher or lower.
So you kind of understand how the model is behaving.
So that's basically of the power of using, let's say
foundry where you get complete visibility into what what's happening
there.
And once you do that, so like Chris said, you
want to eval.
So like I have a eval in here, which basically
shows that each of the samples that you you evaluated,
what's the pass rate or the quality of your evals
that's happening against each of the samples.
So you kind of get, so you pick the particular
model that you're trained and you see that this is
looking like a good number for you.
And if you want to eventually compare across the different
models that Chris talked about the saving cost.
So here is this shows the demonstration of the fact
that 5.2 GBT 5.2 does better base model then you
the Quen 14B would do.
But then as you start taking the smaller model, which
is like significantly cheaper and faster, and then you start
basically doing post training on it that includes distillation, fine
tuning and RFT it you can start seeing the score
go up subsequently, right?
So it's, it's getting better.
You see that the pass rate of the models which
are post trained are better than the ones that are
not.
The rewards are better as well.
And then here, let's say if you particularly pick one
particular sample here, it will show that the score it
got like the 14B initially didn't score as well or
it almost zero and then failed 52 did OK, it
still failed the better score.
So now you start doing SFT of the smaller model,
you start seeing this go up.
So basically you get your score eventually to where you
want it to be.
So this post training can be done in a loop,
like every step can be done individually and it can
be done in a loop and you monitor and you
kind of get it right.
So that's that's where your evals is now.
So this is all of this is fantastic.
This is a code first experience that we saw in
the in foundry.
So here you're provisioning a cluster, you're like Manoj to
come and talk about the cluster as well.
So you're provisioning a cluster, you're managing your array, you're
bringing in the code, you're doing all the infrastructure.
That basically means when you see that the node is
not talking to each other or is the network topology
across the different nodes not as good, you are to
debug the data streaming performance in the network performance and
all of those things.
So it is it is an expert heavy duty work.
But if you want to do something more easier, we
are launching something called we, we, we not named it
yet and I will show you a notebook where this
work.
So the previous one you need to have GPU's.
So everybody in the organization may not have GPU's but
everybody has a laptop.
So here this API that we are doing is a
lower level GPU construct where you are able to just
bring in your RL logic on your laptop, on your
CPU and kick off a job and the job is
kicked off in the server and the server manages all
the infra and everything else it's doing.
So that's.
So in this case, it's a code word.
We're calling it Loom.
It manages the GPU cluster, the images, the environments, like
everything it manages for you and the networking, etc.
And all you have to do is understand four different
GPU constructs.
When you're doing a model training, most of you guys
know it's a forward pass, backward pass where you're optimizing
for a loss function.
So you have access to those core GPU primitives just
like those four.
And that's all you need.
You don't need to worry about how the cluster and
everything else works.
So that's something that you can kind of outsource to
the service.
And then you basically kind of like, so everything on
the left side runs on CPU and your client on
the right side, it runs on the GPU cluster.
And these are the four calls that you basically have
to export and manage.
So now, so the reason why it helps for you
to kind of have this control is, let's say if
you're trying to teach a model linear algebra or mathematics,
right?
You don't want to throw the hardest problem to the
model the fastest.
You want to teach the model how to do basic
arithmetic.
You want to show how to do addition, subtraction, and
gradually kind of climb up the hill to kind of
show linear algebra, calculus, and all of those things.
And you kind of do that in your client.
And the code sample, if you were to do use
this higher level API would look something like this.
This is pretty basic to understand and but it gives
you the maximum control because all you have to say
no cluster, no nothing.
You're just bringing this code in your laptop, in your
notebook and then kind of variation of this.
And you can do both SFT and RFT using this
API and then you set it up.
So that's a notebook.
And then so the jobs, when you submit those jobs
using this API, it'll show up in.
So like the previous jobs that I showed you, it
shows up under train because it's a custom training.
So this the training harness that we have and the
canvas that we have, it allows you to do all
pre training, mid training and everything else is very powerful.
But for the higher level API, these show up in
fine tune.
It's like fine tuning.
So even if you just submit your CPU like script,
it just shows up as a fine tuning both SFT
and RFT.
And then everything about it is like exactly the same.
You can look at the logs, you can see all
the checkpoints that you have.
It takes some time to load, but every single checkpoint.
So when the model is training all the checkpoints, you
can deploy these checkpoints, they all show up here and
you can deploy those checkpoints.
And similarly, just like how we did with code first,
you will have a similar experience for you to dashboard
and then figure out how to basically compare runs across
different things.
And you see here you use any of the highly
APIs, create a job, the reward function goes up.
You see the entropy going down like this is like
what you want to see the group composition climbing up.
So you basically can monitor even again here you can
basically get all the lowest level of visibility that you
want to get for your job.
It's as rich a telemetry and monitoring that you can
got in the code first.
You can get that in the API first as well.
So that's basically the demo.
And then so if you look at now the surface
area of Foundry, So what we are, So what we
are showing you here is the fact that we had
the higher level API today in Foundry.
You have it today where you take a job fire
and forget.
We are introducing 2 new capabilities, which is code first
and the lower level APIs.
They are coming in.
We have a link at the end of it for
private preview.
You guys can sign up.
So anybody who wants to basically come and train using
any of these methods, you can come and train now.
Chris will take over from here and then talk about
desktops.
Vijay, so we talked a lot about training the models,
improving the models.
Now the question is how do you go from a
model that you trained to be able to incorporate it
in an agent?
And the answer is you need to deploy it so
that it can run as an API that gets integrated
with your agent.
And one of the key things that we're proud to
announce at Build today is our foundry managed compute.
What this enables is deploying models, both the serverless trained
models, models that you might have trained on your laptop
or in another model platform, and bring the weights to
Foundry and you can deploy them using Foundry managed compute.
It's a serverless, scalable solution that enables deploying any open
source models or custom models.
And we automatically optimize those.
We scale them out so you can bring your own
weights regardless of where they're trained.
Or you can bring custom models with custom containers that
have highly optimized run times using things like speculative decoding
or draft models to facilitate speeding up the the inference
of these custom models as well.
And so to show you how to do that, I'm
going to ask Manoj to come on stage and walk
you through that.
Hey everyone, I am Manoj.
So we saw how training is done.
I will now talk about deployments.
You need to deploy both base models and fine tune
models, deploy base models to do evals and like see
where the performances and then improve that performance and do
fine tune model deployments.
So here this is the model catalog.
Let's take a quick look at how you deploy base
models.
So I can probably like go to collections and look
at the fireworks models here and the fireworks models like
they let me deploy to a provision throughput unit which
which is our managed offering that gives you predictable performance
at a guaranteed throughput SLA.
So that is the way you deploy, you know, the
models that are available to the fireworks.
And the other option is like what Chris just now
introduced is the managed compute.
So this is basically, yeah.
So this is this will enable you to deploy models
to Foundry managed GPU.
So let me pick up like a model and try
to show you how to deploy it.
I'm trying to find the Quen 32 billion.
Here it is.
When I try to deploy this model I'll pick the
deployment option as managed compute.
This is what we are talking now.
Since the since you are paying for these GPU's you
have couple of options on like how you want to
manage the deployments and how you want to pay for
it.
So here there's an option where you can like run
this model on 2 GPU's and this deploys it with
like.
Enough KV cache to maximize the context length and the
different option is like you, you could probably deploy it
on only one GPU, which is like you know, if
you see here, there is just one GPU is being
used and this is the smallest footprint the model can
run with.
And that is like a just the 40K context length.
I can select both of these and go ahead and
deploy.
But for now, let us switch context a little bit.
You, you saw how to deploy base models.
What about fine-tuned models?
So the fine-tuned models, they show up here in this
list.
When our job runs them, the job automatically registers the
model here.
But if you have trained your fine-tuned model somewhere else
in a different environment, you could import it into the
project.
And we have a command to do that.
And when you import the model to the project, the
most important thing you need to tell us is what
is the base model associated with the model architecture that
you are bringing.
This helps us to identify the right containers and the
right deployment configuration for us to deploy these models.
So you specify the base model, you tell us the
model name, model version, and then you tell us whether
it is a full weight model or adapter that generates
a command and you can copy, paste and run this
command and that model will be imported.
So now that I have the fine-tuned model, I can
go ahead and deploy, sorry, I can deploy this model,
deploying the base model and the fine-tuned model is identical,
no difference whatsoever.
And I can select global managed compute and again the
deployment templates and the same flow where you select the
accelerators, it is the same flow that you I showed
you for the base model.
So I can go ahead and deploy this model as
well.
So this deployment is going to take a couple of
minutes.
So let's let's go look at a model that I
have already already deployed.
Yeah.
So if I come back here to deployments, if I
come back here to deployments, you see that this got
kicked off.
But this is a model at pre deployed.
I can click this model and try out this model
in the playground.
This works great.
We can call this model programmatically.
Here's the code snippet.
This is a chat completions API which means it is
stateless.
So you have to manage the state on your end.
But basically we want to use these models in agent
side what we were showing before.
And to do that you could add this model to
an agent where you get like state management and all
the other capabilities.
I have added that model to an agent here.
So if I if I come to this place the
same fine-tuned model that I showed you, I have already
added it to an agent and now I can again
chat with this.
But the benefit here is that I get like tool
calling so I can say like NBA games, then it
should be able to like pull up real time information
and answer those those queries for me.
So let's look if that happens.
Yeah, so looks like there is a there is a
game today evening.
Yeah.
Now you can see here that this model supports chat
completion like the responses API, which means it will be
able to track your responses.
For example, here as a sample query I had run
where I just said like remember what's my favorite color
and now even though I don't pass the chat history,
I am just passing the previous response, it is able
to recollect that what my favorite color was and informed
me.
So once you have deployed, what becomes important is observability
monitoring and cost management.
So the cost management with managed compute is like available
out-of-the-box.
All deployments can be, you know, all metrics can be
tracked.
So here is a chart where I am tracking the
total tokens consumed by the by the Quen model.
I can add these charts to a dashboard and get
rich monitoring as well.
And finally, when it comes to cost management, I am
able to track and monitor costs for this model.
So here I have focused on the Quen model, I
have filtered by the Quen model and I am able
to see the cost.
Back to you, Chris.
Clearly, training models without deploying them is a waste of
time, so having multiple ways to deploy those models to
do so in a cost efficient and scalable manner is
critically important today.
I hope you've learned several things.
One, there are many models available for your workload.
Foundry has them all, open source and proprietary models.
You can choose them, add them to your agent and
evaluate them on your workload.
So this is critically important.
If it's if it's good enough and it's hitting your
price for performance, fantastic, deploy it.
If not, you can fine tune it.
You can iterate and improve continuously.
You can leverage the new reinforcement learning capabilities, both the
lower level API, full control code of any open source
framework like Slime Girl, TRL, leverage the power of ray
for distribution and monitoring.
You can browse and monitor the quality of the rollouts,
the samples.
You can deeply understand how well the models are performing
and and deploy them in cost efficient manner.
And then you can operate them with control, either leveraging
the new serverless Foundry managed compute offerings on one or
many GPU's, auto scaling with different context lengths and Foundry
makes it easy to configure, deploy and scale to meet
your goals.
And then most importantly, we're automatically collecting all the telemetry
You need to both monitor the costs to create new
data sets to learn from once you've deployed in production
to continuously improve the models.
So you can get started tonight.
We've got all the repo samples published.
You can get the slides later from the same location
that you can get from all the sessions.
Thank you so much.
We've got many other sessions on Foundry to learn how
to deploy it, manage agents and models, all available here.
Thank you for coming tonight.
Appreciate it.